how badly do you want to know your own
nature
if you want to become an nba player if
you want to become
a violinist if you want to become
a grand master in chess how many hours a
week do you think you need to dedicate
yourself to that
you think you can become an nba player
or
a world-class violinist or grandmaster
chess player
if you dedicate yourself five hours a
week
to the craft if you read a couple
pages
of a book or a couple hours
of a video every single week
if you pursue
entrepreneurship
half-assedly will you actually execute
your idea
everyone and their mother knows that
anyone pursuing
entrepreneurship part-time is
significantly less likely to succeed
it's the same exact case with
enlightenment
you have to pursue this full
time earnestness is key
that seeking impulse is the truest thing
about you
period period it's the absolutes
gps callback for you to know yourself
the entire point of this reality is for
you to venture
outward just for you to recognize your
true nature by venturing back
inward that's the entire point of this
you go outward you venture you venture
you seek happiness you seek
peace outside of yourself as a separate
entity
over and over believing that you're a
person believing that this is real that
this is not a dream and you do that
more and more just to
turn inward and wonder what the [ __ ] is
consciousness
what the [ __ ] is awareness am i
infinite is my awareness shared and
eternal with everyone
is this one of our dreams am i the
absolute
and my god am i the highest am i the
ultimate am i the supreme
is this just an expression is this just
a secretion of that
and boom that's when it kicks in that's
the seeking impulse
to know thyself as that is the entire
point
of the reality to dive into that
with earnestness is the entire point of
the reality
and guess what happens as you dive into
that
more and more just like if you're
striving to become an nba player
or if you're striving to become the
world-class violinist
or a grand master in chess guess what
happens
the more you dedicate yourself to it
truly earnestly
time with passion and vigor and desire
for you to know yourself
the more you will literally eradicate
your own
suffering and maximize the prosperity
of yourself and the entire planet
that is the utility of it
it's like cultivating a garden
you can't just expect to
water a little bit every single week
and not care too much about the sunlight
and not really care
for the soil too much you have to
constantly be plucking out the weeds you
have to constantly be managing the soil
managing the sunlight
watering the seed giving it love and
compassion
you have to seek with such earnestness
with such
immovable impenetrable
desire for you to know yourself that you
actually make the truth yield truth will
only yield with the
utmost earnestness to know thyself
but most people don't want the truth to
yield
because it dissolves their ego it
dissolves
their identity as a separate entity
the dissolving of the person is the most
beautiful thing there is
there's nothing more beautiful than
knowing your true nature
it's the most sexy the most attractive
the most courageous thing about people
is when they know themselves
and that's why it was written on the top
of the temple of apollo at delphi
two thousand five hundred years ago the
greeks the number one delphic maxim
know thyself
your true nature as infinity know your
true nature as
nothingness know your true nature as
source as
infinite possibilities know your true
nature
as that which emanates
endlessly
infinite form infinite name
negate negate negate
all the way to source i'm not this
thought
i am not this body
i am not even the awareness
i am source i am nothingness i am
infinity eternally emanating all
creative combinations that
is what i am and then include
include include this creation include
all possible creations include the
thoughts and perceptions and cessations
in your body include all of it
but you have to negate first to truly
know yourself
and you have to seek with earnestness
unbelievable earnestness
only true earnestness
you have to be like an nba player you
have to be like a world-class
athlete you have to be like a
world-class violinist
or a grand master in chess that is the
only way for truth to yield
fast there's no other way for it to
yield fast
your rare candies to level
up quickly come from your earnestness
from your earnestness
suffering is the drill sergeant of
awakening if you are experiencing
lots of suffering it's pressure cooking
you to awaken
take that alchemically transmute it
into your own enlightenment
the entire nature of this reality is all
alchemical
the entire point of it is for awareness
to slowly and more and more
get less and less intoxicated by maya
in its most primal essence
the conscious awareness is
very manipulated by maya it's very
intoxicated by maya
it thinks that the other is actually
another
it thinks that it's a separate entity
and over time the entire point of this
entire
dreamed creation is that awareness
consciousness becomes
less and less manipulated and
intoxicated by maya by the dreamed
creation design you become more
sovereign
you have more prefrontal control
and you're less limbically driven
you have the prefrontal delayed
gratification
capacities to pursue truth
with vigor full time but you are
intoxicated and manipulated by maya
to the degree at which you prioritize
other nonsensical
experiences
but there's a strong desire to pursue
that nonsense in maya because it keeps
the
ego alive it keeps the identity to the
separate entity
alive
but eventually it hits the wall
it hits a breaking point just like in
the parable of the prodigal son
which is an archetype it's the absolute
furthest
that you can tell a story it's the most
extreme you can tell a story
the parable of the prodigal son is such
a
quintessential example of the nature of
reality the
the individuated dreamed illusory
separate self entity wanders
outward and hits a breaking point just
to turn inward to investigate
its source to investigate its own
awareness its own nature its own
potential
infinitude
and upon realization the ego
the separate entity dissolves more and
more
and more until the person becomes
completely dissolved
dissolve the person
your level of earnestness with
dissolving the person is key you want to
die
you want to die you want the person to
die you want to
just become the witness you want to just
become the eternal observer you want to
become
just that that's what you want to be
you want to be the quote i am
that timeless being you want to be the
i am without being
i am this or i am that
stop being the i am this or i
am that that is the most
upstream cause of all of the planetary
suffering
is i over identification with
form with name with what is
transient
you think that you are your body you
think that you are your thoughts you
think that you are your name
and your ethnicity and your career
you think you're all of those things the
i am this
i am that i am all of these things stop
cut it
all off cut all of it off cut every
single last one of those threads off
until you get to just i am
and stay with just pure
timeless being of just i am
that same i am awareness
that is here is the same i am awareness
in you that's
love love is recognizing that we share
our being we share the very i am-ness
stay with that i am stay with it
your earnestness to shed all of the i am
this
i am that's down to just the pure bare
empty awareness of i am
is key it's core to your awakening to
your enlightenment
to eradicating your own suffering and
then eradicating the suffering
of your family your friends enlightening
civilization it starts within begin
with yourself
re-baseline yourself full
time to seek truth
re-baseline yourself to pierce the
veilless veil
full-time full-time
yourself away from the body
away from thoughts away
from form away from
name only become the witness
only become the eternal shared
observer the i am
re-baseline yourself full
time to that full time
that is what is meant by abiding
the self-inquiry of the what is the i
and you penetrate into that witness
and then you penetrate into the abiding
full-time process of holding that
position
more and more it's like doing
repetitions at the gym with
weightlifting it's like when you play
the violin you get better and better and
better the more you do it
you go and you shoot three pointers
until you become
super good at it you learn all of the
different
openings and moves in chess
it's the only way is your earnestness
the only way is the
most dedicated full-time
seeking to recognize your true nature
realize yourself as that
which is witnessing
as that which is eternally observing
recognize the awareness in these
others as the same shared
awareness as yours recognize that we are
all of that witnessing we are that that
is
us we are that
the witness is itself an agent
of source of infinity of the absolute
that's it earnestness is key
people don't want to die people don't
want their ego
to die people don't want their separate
entity to die
people are attached to their identity
they're so attached to the i am this to
the i am
that
that they won't pursue seeking full time
just because of their
level of attachment to identity
and then the drill sergeant comes
respond
to the feather instead of the
sledgehammer
because the [ __ ] sledgehammer
is coming
it's coming you can't run away from it
you can't run away from the evolutionary
force
of the creation it's coming for you
respond to the feather instead of the
sledgehammer
although it may seem difficult to let go
of your attachment to identity into ego
you may as well do it now practice
now get going now before the [ __ ]
sledgehammer comes
know that it's coming
and that should be enough motivation to
respond to the feather right now
it's like you're getting tickled right
now you're like ooh enlightenment
awakening
of the dissolving of the ego
tickle tickle you're gonna pay attention
you're gonna go at it full time right
now is it enough
motivation
because if it is
you get compound interest
you have more neuroplasticity right now
than you will when the sledgehammer
comes
leverage your neuroplasticity
in these more youthful years
you have greater cognitive capacities
to intake all of the data
of the mystic traditions of
enlightenment
it's easier to teach the young
horse new tricks
don't be the old horse on the death bed
that never got to taste their true
nature
got a little dab emoji love it
thanks fam i adore you all thank you
leverage the youthful neuroplasticity
get that compound interest it's the
eighth wonder of the world
you knowing your true nature
younger provides so much more advantage
to the actualization of your gifts
and to the maximizing of planetary
prosperity
and that's why we're so focused on
bringing
the distillation
of the nature of reality down to
the pedagogical level that can be
brought forth in the
generation z and the generation alpha
virtual reality style educational
process
all right you know what to do
earnestness is key
the more earnest you are the faster
truth will yield
of your own true nature the diamond is
already around your neck yet it remains
for you to fully recognize it
do the repetitions the same way
the athletes the same way the world
class
members of symphonies the same way that
grand masters
have to do the repetitions the same way
that you go to the gym to do the
repetitions
is the same way that you have to do the
repetitions
around becoming the witness becoming the
eternal observer recognizing that that
is shared
becoming just i am without the
attachment
to i am this or i am that with identity
with ego
you are what you seek
earnestness is key
i adore you
thank you